[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a choisi de retirer son nom face à
la profusion de candidats et surtout la
confusion de la primaire du Parti
socialiste bonsoir Marie no lman bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous à l'épreuve de
vérité ce rendez-vous que vous propose
chaque Public Sénat avec l'Agence France
Presse avec les échos et avec Radio
Classique sénatrice socialiste frondeuse
donc vous répondrai au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions
d'abord Bernard casenuf Premier ministre
qui vient d'obtenir une large confiance
he de la part des députés vous êtes-il
convaincu avec son discours de politique
générale vous qui n'avez eu de cesse de
combattre son prédécesseur vous le direz
dans un instant à Jean-Francis pecr
ensuite quel sera donc votre choix
maintenant que vous n'êtes plus dans la
course pour la primaire on a envie de
savoir Jérémy Marot de l'AFP vous le
demandera tout à l'heure enfin le PS
miné par les divisions durant tousquin
Kena et puis maintenant dans la
compétition pour 2017 le PS peut-il
mourir question que vous posera Michel
zames mais d'abord une question
d'actualité la France demande dans les
minutes qui viennent une réunion
immédiate donc du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU sur l'épouvantable martyre
d'halepe la pire tragédie humanitaire du
21e siècle a déclaré tout à l'heure
l'ambassadeur de France à l'ONU quel est
votre sentiment Marie Noë linman sur
cette phase finale c'est c'est
l'expression utilisée mais qui est
synonyme on le sait
d'atrocité cette phase finale de la
conquête du bastion rebelle par les
forces syriennes appuyées par la Russie
d'abord j'approuve l'initiative
française de solliciter l'ONU parce que
quelle que soit la situation rien ne
justifie des
massacres évidemment les guerres sont
toujours terribles mais là franchement
la domination militaire n'impose pas
d'aller tuer des enfants massacrer des
gens et cetera et l'humanitaire doit en
tout état de cause toujours s'exprimer
après et plutôt avant on peut
s'interroger maintenant sur la situation
qui a lieu qui n'enlève rien à
l'atrocité qu'il faut absolument essayer
de combattre et d'éviter non mais il
faut d'abord s'interroger sur aussi la
responsabilité de ce qui se passe en ce
moment qui est responsable jeoc bah
d'abord ceux qui les commettent enfin je
veux dire comme je vous le disais il y a
un premier sujet qui est de savoir
est-ce qu'on a bien géré ce dossier
syrien ma réponse est non la preuve mais
est-ce que ça dédouine pour autant ceux
qui passent à l'atrocité et qui font des
massacres non à aucune d'aucune façon la
réflexion qu'on peut avoir c'est comment
on en est arrivé là euh on voit bien
d'ailleurs que dans toute cette zone du
Moyen-Orient du Proche-Orient et cetera
on peut quand même dire que les
Américains ont à l'origine une rest
responsabilité très forte par la grande
déstabilisation qu'a constitué les
guerres d'Irak et cetera la manière dont
l'Occident entre guillemets en tout cas
les Américains ont commencé à
déstabiliser ces régimes qui ont pu être
mis en cause par les printemps et par
les peuples c'est une chose mais que on
instrumentalise tout ça pour être les
grands organisateurs de d'une démocratie
parachutée voire par des bombes ou par
des avions ça je pense que la leçon va
être terrible au regard de l'histoire
estce que le danger numéro 1 ce n'est
pas la récupération de ces révolutions
par par l'islamisme radical qu vous vous
mettez en cause les États-Unis on les a
trouvé très absence dans la dernière
phasà alors mais justement on a une
grande déstabilisation de la
région on a aussi beaucoup de pauvreté
des questions de développement et on a
des batailles à la fois idéologiques la
montée de l'islamisme politique puis
radical puis djihadiste et pas pas
forcément puis et e et vous avez de
l'autre côté un mécanisme aussi qui vise
qui sont d'autres d'une autre nature qui
est l'équilibre historique entre les
chites et les sunnites qui interfère
avec tout cela et qui conduit notamment
à ces massacres aujourd'hui on le voit
avec ses règlements de compte alors on
nous annonce un accord dans les heures
qui viennent un accord d'évacuation des
civils donc et des Rebell d'Alep
également il a été conclu cet accord
sous la houlette de la Russie et de la
Turquie selon un groupe rebelle mais on
le sait ces derniers mois aucun appel
n'a freiné j'y reviens la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui sa victoire
signe l'échec des américain mais aussi
de l'Europe oui absolument mais surtout
je pense qu'on a fait une erreur de
diagnostic sur la la capacité qu'on
avait à euh
courtcircuiter la Russie dans ce dans ce
territoire notammentelle attitude
aujourd'hui adopté avec Vladimir je
voudrais dire que si nous avions dès le
début nous la France était davantage
dans une stratégie si je puis dire de
pont de passerelle entre la vision russe
la vision américaine ou si nous avions
été plus en passerelle entre la vision
des pays du Golf que nous avons quand
même un peu excessivement soutenu et par
exemple les positions iraniennes et
cetera si nous nous étions mis dans la
tradition de la diplomatie française
c'est-à-dire d'être un peu des faiseurs
de paix dans des entre deux ce qui veut
pas dire qu'on est totalement à
éidistance je pense que nous aurions pu
peser davantage en tout cas nous la
France alors alors aujourd'hui vous
prenez pour de meilleures relations avec
la Russie de Vladimir Poutine comme
Donald Trump et d'autres responsabl
politique en moi je pense qu'on ne peut
pas ne pas avoir le dialogue maintenant
j'ai jamais vu de paix qui se conclus
sans qu'il y ait une un dialogue entre
les les belligérants et c'est d'ailleurs
une des erreurs sur à sur
Assad évidemment il n'est absolument en
rien respectable pour autant an pour
faire la paix il faut mettre les partis
en présence et on peut pas mettre un
préalable ça n'a jamais marché donc donc
donc vous estimez qu'il faut dialoger
ave retrouver une solution politique
mais pas seulement avec Poutine
il oui c'est l'homme clé mais
vousz bien sûr mais en même temps il
faut s'attacher à ce que soi les pays de
la région ou la phase dialogue avec
Poutine certes mais faut arriver à ce
que les pays de la région arrivent à pe
même assumer un nouvel équilibre sur ces
territoires donc on renoue le dialogue
avec Vladimir Poutine on lui tend la
main mais on le tient quand même pour
responsable de ce qui se passe en ce oui
parce que à toute étape quand vous
faites la paix vos actes ne sont pas
blanchis parce que vous avez fait la
paix donc là ben la justice
international fera son œuvre et en tout
cas Russ dev rendre des comptes et dier
quand même avec elle voilà il faut que
l'ONU prenne une position sur
l'humanitaire merci première partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant où il
sera question du nouveau au Premier
ministre avec Jean-Francis pecr le
directeur de la rédaction de Radio
Classique
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir Jean-Francis bonsoir
Michel bonsoir Marie Noël linman alors
ce soir Bernard casazneuf sur son
discours de politique générale a obtenu
une large confiance à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que cette confiance
vous vous la lui auriez donné je pense
que dans le contexte actuel et au regard
de la personnalité de la manière dont il
a présenté sa sa feuille de route je
crois que je lui aurais donné parce que
toute une série de dés acccords
politiques que nous avons sur les sur ce
qui a été entrepris durant le quinquen
de François Hollande tout le monde le
connaît et il va être d'une certaine
façon arbitré par la primaire à travers
les votes qui seront évidemment pas que
des votes de bilan mais quand même un
regard sur le bilan pour se projeter sur
l'avenir donc je pense que c'est pas à
cette étape qu'il faut mettre en cause
le le bilan de François Hollande et le
nouveau gouvernement par ailleurs vous
l'avez fait depuis 5 ans hein oui mais
parce qu'on était dans une phase où on
espérait encore une réorientation il
vous a pas échappé que le chef de l'État
n'est pas candidat donc c'est pas lui
qui va porter les propositions d'avenir
et il ne vous a pas achppé non plus
qu'il nous reste que un temps très
compté et que c'est pas à ce moment-là
qu'on fait des changements brutaux j'ai
apprécié dans ces propos la combativité
à défendre notre modèle social j'aurais
préféré qu'il soit appuyé sur des actes
un petit peu plus fort par le passé et
peut-être des engagements immédiats je
prends un exemple je pense que on entend
partout débattre sur je veux valoriser
le travail enfin j'ose espérer que tout
le monde veut valoriser le travail ça ça
on entend ça depuis Sarkozi il y aurait
ceux qui seraient les fait néants à
titré et par exemple je trouve qu'il
aurait pu annoncer une un coup de pouce
au SMIC SMIC mais ça c'est c'était votre
programme pour la c'est le mien mais en
même temps c'est aussi une question
d'attente vous voyez que les Français
sont très attend de pouir vousz écouté
Bernard casneu il assume tout il assume
tout le bilan il assume le bilan de
Jean-Marc erud et le bilan de Manuel
Vals notamment sur ces réformes
libérales en quoi est-ce qu'il est
différent de Manuel Vals Bernard casenu
il est pas fondamentalement différite
votre confiance non il mérite pas notre
confiance là on fait pas un vote pour
dire un blancin sur tout ce qu'il a dit
on considère que la feuille de route qui
met en place n'est pas ne pouvait pas
être une feuille de route de rupture et
elle ne provoque aucun malaise
supplémentaire à celui que nous avons
déjà et il est plutôt dans une tonalité
assez offensive au regard des menaces
qui pèse sur notre modèle social c'est
donc absolument pas une confiance en
disant youi vive Bernard casneu c'est
une confiance raisonnable car le pays a
besoin d'être dirigé et manifestement en
cohérence entre le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre
prenons si vous voulez bien un certain
nombre de choses qu'il compte mettre en
œuvre dans les 5 mois qui lui restent et
not et en parti particulier
l'augmentation du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi qui va passer de 6
% de la masse salarial en 2016 à 7 % en
2017 c'est une mesure que vous combattez
oui elle était le CIC en soi je le
combat pas tant parce qu'il incarne des
allègements de cotisation que par le
fait qu'il y ait aucune contrepartie qui
ne soit réel en terme d'emploi ou
d'investissement une stratégie je
rappelle qu'à l'origine il était pour
nous permettre d'avoir une reconquête
dans la mondialisation actuelle il a
permis aux entreprises de reconstituer
leur Marg oui mais les marges n'ont pas
servi à massivement créer des emplois
elles n'ont pas servi non plus à
massivement augmenter les bas salaires
car s'il peut y avoir ici ou là des
augmentations de de salaire elles sont
souvent très individualisées et pas
collectifes sur les bas salaires
l'emploi les
14 il partout en Europe même par
maintenant oui sauf que 140000 les
entreprises ont constitué leur marge
effectivement comme le dit mais d'accord
mais simplement je vous dis que c'est
140000 emplois existent dans les pays
qui n' pas fait ces marges non qui
n'avait pas fait le cice et je constate
que les contreparties quand je prends le
nombre d'emplois créés regardez sommes
qui ont été versées je considère que la
stratégie que nous proposions de
contrepartie était fondée il est clair
que dans certains secteurs moi j'ai
toujours dit dans l'industrie faut aider
à fond la caisse la modernisation de
l'industrie
et son investissement et la reconquête
de marché extérieur je n'ai aucun éatâ
sur les aides à apporter au secteur
industriel au services liés au secteur
industriel truc en revanche il y a des
secteurs entiers qui ont touché le cice
qui n'en avait pas besoin je on prend
régulièrement la grande distribution la
grande distribution n'en avait pas
besoin et là il me semble que justement
ma proposition sur le SMIC était si je
puis dire il y a deux stratégies on dit
faut remettre en cause cice soit on dit
on vous a donné des marches le temps est
venu de donner des contreparties en bas
salaire question là encore Bernard ku
dit il faut poursuivre les réformes qui
ont été engagées par Manuel Vass pour
restaurer notre compétitivité est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça je ne suis
pas d'accord avec une partie de ces
réformes mais je suis d'accord avec une
autre par exemple je suis d'accord sur
les avantages qui sont donnés pour
l'investissement productif vous savez le
la fameuse le l'amortissement ils vontir
DESS oui justement Ilir moi cette mesure
là j'aurais je pense qu'elle est la elle
terminer fin avril 201 que ces réforme
là et j'espère mener ces débats jusqu'au
bout j'aurais d'ailleurs aimé pouvoir le
faire au moment du Budet c'est le sur
c'est le suram voilà que moi j'avais
défendu dès le début du quinena car
j'observe que on compare souvent les
capacités de l'Italie et de la France à
exporter et que l'Italie a fait ce
principe sur 5 ans c'est-à-dire a donné
de la visibilité au SE industriel sur la
robotisation la modernisation
l'investissement numérique je regrette
qu'on ne le fasse pas donc moi je suis
vous nes pas hostile à tout ce qui
relève de l'aide aux entreprises donc
moi j'ai toujours dit des aides aux
entreprises à condition qu' des
contreparties ou qu'ell correspondent à
des ciblage jugé prioritaire pour la
nation comment comprendre que les
frondeurs que vous soutenez qui ont voté
contre les gouvernements de votre
majorité jusque là vote la confiance à
Bernard casenu
ès tout leonde a compris que débatait
pas lie sur le la confiance au Premier
ministre et qu'il avait lieu sur
qu'est-ce que nous allons faire avant
c'est pas maintenant qu'on change de
politique donc on a le sentiment l que
l'on vous écoute que vous l'avez voté
parce que vous considérez que ce
discours de politique générale au fond
il avait pas d'importance c'est
ça il n'avait pas une importance
capitale et en tout c'est un événement
oui d'une certaine façon mais en même
temps on voit que Bernard casneu est un
homme sérieux donc il y a pas non plus
de il a toujours souci de de d'être
pédagogue de rassembler d'écouter il y
avait donc pas de raison de mettre un a
priori ou un ouas sur la personne il
était évident qu'on allait pas avoir un
changement de politique économique
j'aurais préféré quelques inclinaisons
elles viennent pas mais l'étape n'est
plus à régler ce problème à l'Assemblée
mais dans le cadre des primes d'accord
d'accord donc vous considérez que c'est
la période des adieux et qu'il faut que
ça se passe dans le calme enfin pas que
des adieux parce que quand même encore 6
mois il y a des choses bah il y a des
choses à faire bon par exemple ils vont
prolonger les les stagees pour les
500000 jeunes c'est plutôt positif oui
enfin plutôt les emplois qui ne sont pas
bien pourvu bon tout ça est positif mais
ça ne règle rien est-ce que vous avez eu
le sentiment d'entendre un premier
ministre en action au gouvernement ou un
premier ministre en campagne électorale
déjà un peu des deux mais c'est bien
normal c'est bien normal que le premier
ministre éclaire les Français sur si eux
n'assument pas le bilan qui va le faire
bon moi je suis pas d'accord avec leur
bilan mais après tout il y a des gens
qui peuvent assumer le bilan et qui nous
expliquent en quoi ils le trouvent
positif moi ils ne m'ont pas convaincu
on voilà le débat a lieu alors le
premier ministre est intervenu également
sur l'Europe pas seulement sur bien sûr
les aides aux entreprises il a salué les
investissements rendus possibles par le
plan Junker en disant que la France
avait pesé de tout son poids il a assuré
que les fraudes aux travailleurs
détachés hein seraient traqué plus
encore que jusqu'à présent et il a eu
cette
formule l'Europe enfin doit défendre ses
intérêts dans la
mondialisation je crois comme beaucoup
d'entre vous à l'Europe ouverte mais je
refuse l'Europe offerte les accords
commerciaux doivent garantir la loyauté
des échanges la réciprocité dans l'accès
au au marché public la prise en compte
des normes sociales et
environnementales parole parole
dites-vous oui je dis pas enfin je
parole parole parce que je commence à
être Lass comme beaucoup comme la
plupart des Français de ces discours sur
l'Europe qui ne qui ne se concrétisent
en rien en rien du tout premier exemple
vous prenez les travailleurs détachés
alors on nous avait expliqué qu'en 2014
on avait amélioré la directive bon il y
en a de plus en plus alors on nous dit
et c'est vrai qu'il y a une mesure
intéressante notamment pour les
chantiers dans le bâtiment de la fameuse
carte qui va permettre faut-il encore
qu'on ait assez d'inspecteur du travail
pour aller régulièrement et notamment le
weekend notamment en dehors des heures
habituelles de travail sur les chantiers
car il vous a pas échappé qu'il arrivait
que le lundi matin on découvre qu'il a
beaucoup de travail qui a été fait
pendant le weekend euh et on se demande
par quelle opération ça s'est réalisé
donc moi je le dis tout nê sur les
travailleurs détachés je ne crois plus à
ce type de discours je préconise et je
le préconise depuis long longtemps j'ai
pas attendu les articles je leur dis
depuis le début la France doit expliquer
à ses partenaires européens qu'il y a
des sujet où la ligne rouge ne sera pas
franchie et où la France doit dire nous
suspendons unilatéralement puisque
voulez pas la suspendre la directive
travailleurs détachés et nous nous
remettons on n'interdit pas les
travailleurs détachés on remet un
agrément pour être sûr que l'entreprise
va bien correspondre à des besoins réel
qu'on va faire justement avec ce cette
carte c'estàdire qu'on ne pourra plus
ouvrir un chantier si on a pas vous
parlez du bâtiment mais il y a les
tr/art du secteur ne sont pas dans le
bâtiment non mais on n'aura pas à ouvrir
le chantier beaucoup le bâtiment non
mais moi je souhaite qu'on dise
clairement que c'est on a 286000
travailleurs détachés vous m'avez parler
tout à l'heure du fait le premier
ministre a dit qu'on aurait créé 240000
emplois marchands je dis je dis que
c'est que ces emplois sont antinomiques
avec l'intérêt de la nation donc nous
devons appeler à la clause de sauvegarde
garde et il y a une autre raison c'est
que si nous ne disons jamais non à
l'Europe sur rien jamais on aura
l'Europe sociale jamais parce que il y a
toujours des bonnes raisons les Polonais
espèrent développer sur le dumping les
Allemands espèrent utiliser le dumping
de leurs voisins de l'Est et cetera la
France doit peser de tout son poids elle
doit poser l'E europeope sociale est-ce
que c'est pas aussi cette Europe de la
mobilité des travailleurs entre l'Est et
l'Ouest entre les différents pays
d'Europe c'est ça le projet européen
aussi
ça c'est la liberté de travailler dans
au sein de l'espace économique pas du
tout c'est pas du tout ça Jean jores le
disait déjà à
l'époque bien avant oui mais justement
c'était bien avant aussi la pseudo
modernité de de la mondialisation
l'Europe sociale c'est des convergence
sociale c'est un espace social qui qui
converge économiquement et socialement
vers des standards élevés et qui ne met
pas en concurrence les peuples au nom de
la mobilité avec un dumping social ou un
dumping fiscal c'est cette Europe là qui
amène les gens à se détourner de cette
Europe la la fameuse Europe d'origine
des paires fondateur celle de charbon et
de l'acier elle était à la fois une
Europe qui se protège un grand marché
qui se protégeait par rapport à
l'extérieur préférence communautaire
elle était aussi avec des politiques
sociales pour le charbon et l'acier
c'est-à-dire on essayait d'éviter
d'avoir du dumping on organisait
harmonieusement pourquoi pas la mobilité
mais sans dumping voilà
merci Marie Noël linman merci dernière
question le Premier ministre a annoncé
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence vous
l'approuvez ben je m'étais abstenu la
fois dernière je m'abstiendrai cette
fois-ci encore je pour une raison
purement politique c'estàd je ne crois
pas du tout à l'efficacité de la
prolongation d'état d'urgence je partage
d'ailleurs l'avis de mes collègues qui
pensent qu'il faut qu'on on limite le en
en
durée l'interdiction de résidence
l'obligation de résidence moi je ne
crois pas l'efficacité de cela en même
temps je vois bien dans une période
électorale tout sera instrumentalisé
pour expliquer que c'est du laxisme et
cetera donc dans dans la période je
m'abstiens d'accord merci encore
Jean-Francis les deuxè parti de
l'épreuve de vérité avec Jérémy Marot de
l'Agence France Presse qui nous rejoint
l' preuve de vérité avec
laafp bonsoir Jérémy et bienvenue sur le
plateau de pu c'est votre première votre
question évidemment la question que le
monde se pose après votre retrait de la
primaire qui soutiendrez-vous pour cette
primaire je ne crois pas que les
Français soient en pleine trans
d'attente de ma réponse dans ce premier
tour de la de la primaire je ne souhaite
pas prendre position pour l'un des deux
candidats de la gauche du PS ou des
frondeurs comme on veut les appeler
parce que je veux pouvoir garder ma
liberté de ton et ma liberté de
proposition car j'observe qu'un certain
nombre de de sujets que je porte à mon
avis mérite d'être mieux porté par l'un
et l'autre il y en a d'A peut-être vous
réservez pour d'autres candidats
éventuels en plus et à côté de de de
monbour c'est l' des deux non c'est l'un
des deux qui aurait ma préférence et
aura ma préférence au deème tour car je
ne doute pas que l'un des deux sera le
candidat qui sera opposé au deème tour
mais deux de vos vos plus proches
soutiens Emmanuel Morel et Jér qui ont
pris position monbour c'est un secr
poinel vous allez vous non non c'est pas
vous ne me ferez pas dire ce que je ne
veux pas dire
premièrement je vous ai dit que je
voulais garder ma liberté de parole et
de ton pour les propositions parce
queche pas ça n'empêche pas gardez votre
liberté jusquà la fin de cette émission
mais je vous dir pas et je vais vous
dire pourquoi imaginez que je soutienne
l' ou l'autre je vais dire faut
augmenter le SMIC on va dire ah machin
que je soutiens et pour l'augmentation
du SMIC si lui il veut pas alors je vais
dire moi marine non bon deuxièmement je
vais vous dire je pense qu'il faut
quelqu'un qui soit un petit peu attentif
au fait que l'intérêt général les
convergences priment sur la tentation
bien légitime quand il y a un premier
tour de mettre en exerg ces différences
et je vois bien déjà les amis d'Arnaud
ou ceux de Benoît mettre en exerg oui
comment l'autre il est pas si bien que
ça sur tel sujet et cetera je leur dis
prenez garde le temps est court il
faudra converger et ce qui est important
infin c'est est-ce qu'on est capable de
rassembler une majorité qui soit
alternative à la ligne Hollande Vals et
je ne sais qui d'autrre qui en fait
défend la même stratégie que j'appelle
social libéral vous allez dire qu'on a
l'esprit retort mais il se murmure quand
même que vous avez un accord secret avec
Benoît mon mais alors c'est ça c'est ça
les laissez-moi l'expliquer en deux mot
vous auriez accepté de vous retirer à la
primaire en échange benoî amamont
acceptait lui de retirer une candidate
qui lui est proche de la list
sénatoriale et qui aurait été en
concurrence avec vous non mais si vous
saviez le nombre de pressions que j'ai
eu divers var
elles viennent de tous les bords les
amis d'Arnaud Marie Noël ce serait bien
que tu quand même au premier tour machin
les amis de Benoît et Benoît idem
faudrait que tu te retires et cetera je
vais vous dire une chose dans ma vie
politique j'ai toujours assumé
personnellement mes choix et mes choix
ils ont été fondés assez tôt sur une
réalité qui était que je voyais comment
la dispersion je ne faisais pas une
réunion sur le terrain sans que les gens
me disent Marie Noël pourquoi vous
n'arrivez pas à vous mettre d'accord
alors moi je disais je suis d'accord
pour qu'on trouve des convergences phase
1 je l'ai même dit à notre fameuse
université d'été de La Rochelle et j'ai
observé que tout le monde dit qu'il faut
qu'on converge et que tout le monde
pense que ça peut converger vers
lui-même ou vers elle-même moi j'ai fait
le diagnostic peut-être erroné mais il
me semble que je n'étais pas en
situation de de pouvoir être la
candidate unique à partir de ce
moment-là j'ai considéré que ayant mis
sur la table des deses propositions
étant bien déterminé à continuer à les
porter notamment une politique de
relance que certains appellent
kénésienne roseveltienne évidemment
écosocialiste on va pas faire du
Roosevelt aujourd'hui et ben je pense
que il fallait que je me retire parce
que la dispersion et on l'a vu à la
primière de la droite la dynamique du
premier tour est déterminante pour le
second vous dites il faut se rassembler
il faut converger 2 jours après votre
retrait on a une nouvelle candidature
celle de oui est- que on est à combien 7
9 10 candidat potentiel je pense qu'il y
en aura moins parce que tout le monde a
ben je pense que ça n'est pas à
mobiliser l'autre raison qui était la
mienne c'était que je voulais que les
gens sentent que cette prère était utile
qu'elle était importante que c'est là
que pouvait jouer peut-être le rebond de
la gauche pour l'élection présidentielle
puisqu'on nous annonce partout la gauche
laminée dispersée et cetera donc je
pense que nous avons tout intérêt à ce
que le débat se cristallise de manière
claire entre deux grands caps
stratégiques évidemment aucun des
candidats ne va faire comme Monsieur
Fillon mon programme tout mon programme
à moi tout seul c'est des Caps
stratégiques soit on est on continue
dans la logique qui a été celle du
gouvernement social libéral donc vous
dites social modérato libéral plutôt
fort mais moi je préconise une stratégie
que je qualifie de non libéral
républicaines et des écocialistes de
relance mais au milieu il y a donc
Vincent payon alors lui il dit qu'il est
le cœur de la gauche il se présente
comme le candidat de rassemblement non
ça pourrait pas vous convenir bah
écoutez enfin je ne sais même pas ce que
propose Vincent à l'état actuel des
choses donc moi je je je pense que de
toute façon il arrive un peu dans le jeu
de nulle part et la première chose qu'il
dit c'est qu'il est d'accord avec le
bilan de François Hollande donc moi je
peux pas être d'accord avec François
avec Vincent payon voilà maintenant si
je puux dire que les amis qui défendent
François Hollande manuel d'autres
trouvve les moyens de de trouver leur
convergence moi je travaille au con oui
c'est c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
fallait pas rajouter les miettements
pour vous la candidature de Vincent
payon c'est une candidature improvisée
uniquement antials je n'en sais rien ENF
quand même on peut dire que sans être
grand clair ça ça ressemble beaucoup à
ça mais vous n'avez pas envie de
participer vous à un mouvement tout SAU
Vals non je ne pense pas que la période
soit dans le tout sauf quelqu'un je
pense que la période est dans
l'affirmation un projet qui mobilise les
Français et je le dis d'autant plus que
je pense que le fait que la droite
française soit à rebour de l'histoire
avec des politiques ultraalibérales
devrait donner à la gauche des chances
plus qu'elle ne le croit donc c'est le
fond qui compte aujourd'hui manuel Vals
dont vous ne voulez plus entendre parler
se présente comme le candidat de la
révolte ça devrait vous plaire mais il a
également défendu en ses termes son
positionnement on l'écoute et vous
réagissez Marie no linman c'est la
gauche qui est la plus à même de
rassembler autour des valeurs de la
République les Français demain donc
j'avance et je veux incarner d'une
certaine manière ça vous rappellera
quelque chose une force tranquille le
pays a besoin d'une belle et force
tranquille bah je suis d'accord sur le
diagnostic que c'est la gauche qui peut
rassembler le pays sur les thès
républicaine sauf que je suis en total
désaccord sur la manière dont on on
décline aujourd'hui ces thèses
républicaines vous savez pour moi la
République c'est d'abord l'égalité c'est
d'abord la justice sociale c'est d'abord
la souveraineté populaire par rapport
aux lois du marché
c'est par exemple aussi l'idée que l'on
a on doit acceptter un cadre commun et
on n'accepte pas la loi du plus fort bon
voilà tout ça je nai l'ai pas trouvé
dans le quinquenat de François Hollande
ni dans les politiques de Manuel Vals je
ne dis pas que tout a été négatif je
suis très favorable au tiers payant
généralisé ou à des choses comme ça donc
effectivement l'enjeu c'est la gauche
peut-elle porter le projet républicain
du 21e siècle ma réponse est oui mais ma
réponse c'est la gauche que nous
incarnons celle qui a refusé les dérives
libérales qui peut aujourd'hui
l'incarner et la force tranquille
la ministre oui de François mitteran et
j'ai je ne je pense que vous savez nous
sommes dans un mot dans une période où
je dis au responsables politiques de
tout bord faisons attention de d'avoir
un langage qui colle avec ce qu'on fait
un langage de vérité par rapport à ce
qu'on fait fait et ce qu'on dit parce
que faire que des mots clés euh je suis
par exemple que vous avez Macron qui dit
je défends le travail ah ben d'accord je
défends le travail candidat du travail
alors déjà je suis mais pas tellement
des travailleurs parce que quand vous
regardez de près il vous dit Macron je
vais augmenter le salaire réel parce que
je vais baisser les cotisations payées
par les salariés et les faire payer par
la CSG je vous rappelle que la grande
majorité de la CG est payé par les
salariés même s'il est vrai que c'est un
petit peu mieux que quand on fait que de
la cotisation la parte beaucoup plus l
voilà oui mais elle est beaucoup plus
large mais elle tombe quand même
massivement sur les salarié donc le vrai
gain salarial va être finalement modeste
deuxièmement il ne touche en rien au
rapport capital travail je vous parlais
par exemple du CCE d'entreprise qui
certes maintenant qu'elles ont
reconstitué leur marge elles ont pas
besoin qu'on continue à leur mettre des
des des avantages fiscaux à fond la
caisse donc il pourrait reprendre mon
idée sur l'augmentation des salaires qui
qui elle valorise réellement le travail
par rapport au capital et dans le vécu
des citoyens et le mot comme ça il plaît
c'était comme quand Sarco disait disait
je défends le travail et puis la réalité
c'est que l'augmentation du nombre de
chômeurs a été considérable et le
pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes et
des classes qui travaillent et des gens
qui travaillent a été au mieux stagnant
au pire en baisse voilà donc moi je
demande au leader politique et c'est la
même chose sur la force tranquille on
peut pas avoir la force tranquille quand
on fracasse pendant des années et des
années au pouvoir sa propre majorité sur
le thème il y a deux gauches
réconciliiables les gars et puis 493 et
vous avez rien compris à la
mondialisation et la loi travail et
cetera et cetera et maintenant on arrive
la force tranquille d'un seul coup on
est rentré dans le monde des bisounours
non franchement je pense qu'il faut de
la cohérence de la solidité et bon je ne
prends acte de la volonté d'apaisement
de Manuel Vals mais je crains que ça ne
suffise pas pour convaincre non on on
parlait d'Emmanuel Macron lui il est
comme manemmanuel Vals il en rve il a il
sont t révolt ils aiment pas le système
révolution pas est-ce qu'il doit
participer la à la primère de de la
gauche écoutez moi je pense qu'il a dit
non il a dit non maintenant c'est clair
et Mélenchon a dit non c'est pas la
peine de faire comme si on a répondu
quand j'ai proposé à mes amis d'avoir
une candidature unique manifestement ils
m'ont répondu non je fais pas comme si
il y avait pas eu de réponse en revanche
comme vous le disiez regardez les cart
des mot les voilà qui sont
révolutionnaires qui sont pour le qui
sont pour la révolte ils sont
l'incarnation du système c'est eux qui
ont poussé à toutes ces politiques qui
nous ont mis dans le mur et qui ont qui
ont mis en difficulté toute une série de
catégories sociales et qui ont fracassé
la gauche et maintenant c'est les voilà
ils sont pas dans le système ils ont été
banquiers ils ont été au ministère ils
ont fait le rapport à thali mais ils
sont où si ce n'est dans le cœur du C du
jug parce que si vous citez Emmanuel
Macron c'est lui qui incarne la
dynamique aujourd'hui hein ah mais je
NIS pas que quand il y a 15000 personnes
il y a une dynamique mais quelle est
cette dynamique est-ce que c'est pas une
dynamique pour une large part de droite
et une partie de la gauche euh qui se
sent plutôt bien intégré euh et moi je
pense que c'est c'est là où j'avais déjà
un désaccord lourd avec Manuel je pense
que la gauche quelle soit la gauche
qu'on peut considérer comme bien intégré
de classe moyenne qui espère une société
plus juste et plus douce euh et de
l'autre côté la gauche qui souffre les
salariés qui sont écrasés par la
mondialisation et qui eux finissent par
avoir une colère profonde c'était à nous
de trouver les réformes qui fédèent ces
gens-là et c'est encore ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse aujourd'hui et je ne pense
pas qu'ils soi en situation de allez ils
sont congédiés tous les deux dernière
question Jérémy congédier vous l'avez
dit le Parti socialiste se targue
d'appliquer la parité oui au primaire à
cette primaire on ne voit aucune femme
alors peut-être que Sylvia Pinel va la
va la rejoindre il n'y a aucune femme
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire c'est un
regret mais en même temps alors beaucoup
me disaient oui dans les pressions mais
Marie Noë tu peux partir er ta
candidature faut une femme mais moi je
suis pas jeis une femme mais je suis une
politique donc moi je fais mon choix au
regard de ce que je pense et de
l'intérêt de la cause que je défend
alors si une femme permet de le faire
bien à une période et si à une autre
période elle considère qu'elle est pas
indispensable moi j'aurais jamais fait
femme petige pour dire il y a une femme
voilà cela dit c'est quand même
révélateur dans les périodes de crise
les femmes qui sont plutôt fédératrices
ont un peu de mal souvent à s'affirmer
dans ces périodes audelà merci beaucoup
Jérémy dernière partie de l'épreuve de
vérité Marie Noël linman avec Michel
zames de Public
[Musique]
Sénat bonsoir Michel bonsoir Michel
bonsoir Marie Noë lman bonsoir alors le
Parti socialiste peut-il mourir après
2017 alors votre votre question une
bonne question
comm c'est ce qui me meurtre déjà c'est
que Manuel Val commc son quinquenin
enant la gauche peut mourir déjà une
espèce de et c'est là qui vous il nous
intimit l'ordre entre guillemets he
l'ordre nous intimit la une mutation
sociale libérale qui manifestement ne
convain personne pour lui le fait que la
gauche était déjà morte quelque part et
et parce que parce que l'idée qui se
fait de la gauche il croit que nous
sommes disqualifiés moi je fais le
diagnostic inverse je pense
qu'aujourd'hui partout dans le monde il
y a un reflux libéral et là
la dominante de la réponse dans le monde
elle est populiste Trump elle est
d'extrême droite de repli d'identitaire
sous différentes formes il y a une autre
réponse et dans l'histoire il y a
toujours eu d'autres réponses à à cette
à à ce reflux libéral c'est une
politique de gauche de justice sociale
de redistribution de relance sa que si
vous permettez en Europe aujourd'hui les
travaillistes les socialistes au pouvoir
mais ils ont échoué et si on regarde un
peu plus loin les contestataires par
exemple en Grèce pour simplement mais
ils ont été eux aussi ont été condamnés
et donc ça marche pas bien sûr attendez
toute façon rien ne marche parce que je
m'excuse où est-ce que vous voyez
quelque chose qui marche à part en
Allemagne Madame Merkel qui reste dans
la fidélité mais il y a un pays il y a
un pays qui fait son son sa richesse sur
le dos des autres qui veulent bien
accepter d'être les dons de la farce en
l'occurrence nous par exemple et il y a
un pays qui se trouve le grand
bénéficiaire du système européen c'est
l'Allemagne donc la stabilité ça
fonctionne néanmoins j'observe que même
en Allemagne Madame Merkel n'avait pas
eu sa majorité toute seule la fois
dernière d'où la nécessité de mettre un
SMIC européen donc la question sociale
c'était un SMIC allemand donc la
question sociale la nécessité de
coalition non d'où la question sociale
interfère de toute façon dans les choix
d'aujourd'hui donc moi je dis que là
normalement le PS et la gauche devrait
être au rendez-vous de l'histoire mais
est-ce que vous même vousz que la la la
gauche de la du Parti socialiste que
vous incarnez est réconciliable donc
avec sa frange social libérale que vous
dénoncer émission pour vous l'ANT pour
moi la question centrale est de savoir
si aujourd'hui on va avoir au Parti
socialiste un PS qui est au centre de
gravité de la gauche qui peut donc
rassembler largement l'ensemble des
forces de gauche ou si le PS se range
définitivement comme on a essayé de nous
emmener sur ce tropisme vers un pseudo
centregauche qui va passer dans les
tourbillons de l'histoire c'est l'enjeu
aujourd'hui de la primaire mais c'est
l'enjeu de l'élection présidentielle
c'est pas seulement l'enjeu de
l'élection présidentielle c'est c'est
l'enjeu de la bien sûr de l'élection
présidentielle de savoir si la gauche va
être au rendez-vous ou si elle va être
complètement explosé dans ces dans ses
propositions c'est aussi l'enjeu des
législatives car de mon point de vue on
ne peut pas arrêter la vie politique en
disant uniquement la question de la
présidentielle moi j'ai toujours plaidé
pour qu'il y ait un programme commun
entre guillemets je sais que le mot fait
vieillot mais avec l'ensemble des forces
de gauche qui sont prêtes à gouverner
donc de Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Manuel Vals
et cetera la question c'est où est le où
est le cœur où est la décision où est le
centre de gravité si c'est la logique de
Manuel Vals il aura il ne peut pas être
le centre de gravité la preuve en est
faite puisque je ne vois pas pourquoi
François hand n'arrive pas à rassembler
Emmanuel Vals qui est encore plus
percuté au moins psychologiquement euh
pourrait le faire donc la question
centrale c'est le PS ne peut survivre
que s'il reste un parti qui un se met au
centre de gravité de la gauche dans ses
propositions dans ses combats et de s'il
reste lié à une volonté farouche et
déterminée de rassemblement de toutes
les forces de gauche et ne sombre pas
dans le tropisme du centre gauche qui
aura peut-être son temps à l'élection
présidentielle ne résistera pas
longtemps au duretés de la période
Vincent payon dit que l'une des erreurs
du quinquena c'est ne pas avoir tendu la
main à à Monsieur Baayou en 2012 oui ben
je pense exactement la faire je vais
vous dire sur monsieur Baayou je
distingue deux choses j'ai j'ai vous
savez que j'ai fait un livre qui
s'appelle merci pour ce changement et
j'ai considéré que dès le début du
quinena François Hollande était déjà
dans une TR stratégie perdante j'allais
dire une tratégie tragédie perdante
pourquoi parce que normalement quand
vous êtes élu avec 51 % des voix au
moins au début de votre quinena vous
vous attachez à rassembler tout tous
ceux qui ont concouru à votre victoire
or le gros du paquet qui avait concouru
à sa victoire c'était l'ensemble des
force autour du Parti socialiste puisque
il n'a pas été d'une grande tendresse et
écoute en direction de Martin auri les
communistes et les électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et il est vrai que
personnellement François Baayou avait
apporté 5 ans je ne suis pas favorable
une alliance au centre en plus le centre
n'est jamais là quand vous avez besoin
de lui la preuve regardez alin Jupé
c'est phrase n'est pas de moi elle est
de François mitteran donc le mais par
contre j'avais trouvé inélégant de ne
pas permettre à François baayrou d'être
élu député parce que sa voix pouvait
apporter quelque chose au débat
politique mais en tout cas moi je suis
arquebouté sans les rassemblements des
forces de gauche écologistes rouge rose
vert nous n'arriverons pas ni à gagner
ni à transp de franç mitteran de
l'époque de Lionel Jospin c'est bien ça
oui mais à la différence de l'époque de
Lionel Jospin j'ai déjà critiqué à cette
époque des alliances qui étaient des
alliances bilatérales sans qu'on cherche
à avoir une plateforme commune qui
rassemble les uns et les autres or nous
avons besoin d'une plateforme et d'un
programme qui parle aux gens qui
répondent à leurs questions réel
d'aujourd'hui et juste une dernière
question vous demandez quoi aujourd'hui
un changement de nom du parti socialiste
surtout pas je suis pour maintenir le
mot de Parti socialiste je fais partie
des gens que ce mot pensent que ce mot
n'est pas disqualifié au contraire alors
et vous dites qu'il faut séduire le la
plus grande masse bien sûr de français
les couches populaires les oui il faut
reconquérir les couches populaires qui
aujourd'hui les couches moyenne qui vous
ont déserté
exactement notamment au profit du Front
national exactement une partie d'entre
ell écout le politologue Laurent Bouvet
justement qui estime évidemment que sans
ces couches populaires et ces couches
moyennes et bien aucune victoire
électorale n'est possible euh et on le
sait donc ces couche populaire se tourne
aujourd'hui vers le Front national pas
toujours pas toutes non plus hein il
beaucoup par l'abstention aussiz réagir
en grande partie on écoute le
politologue mais par ailleurs il y a une
captation par le Front national c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui mais là ça s'est
accéléré ces dernières années c'est bien
clair euh du vote ce qu'on appelle les
catégories populaires alors c'est les
CSP les catégories sociopressionnelles
ouvriers employés les jeunes issus de
ces catégories et les retraité issu de
ces catégories ce qui fait 60 plus de 60
% de du corps électoral français il faut
jamais l'oublier hein donc c'est très
c'est une masse hein qui n'a pas les
catégorie populaire avec lui ne peut pas
être élu président de la République et
quand vous regardez les chiffres de
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2017 2012 ils sont
élus avec catégorie
populaireman B exactement je pense ça je
pense que les catégories populaires ne
vont pas toutes vers le FN mais une
partie va vers l'abstention reste que
l'enjeu de la reconquête des couches
populaires c'est mon combat depuis
toujours je c'est le Front National qui
a réussi nos pa quand
même tout en tout cas il est clair que
dans le Nord patcala les gens qui votent
Front national il votaient à gauche
avant hein ah bah à la politique de la
gauche pour une large part qui n'a pas
été au rendez-vous de l'attente de ces
gens-là quand on leur a expliqué donc
demain si par exemple AR Montebourg
benoî mon celui que vous choisirez entre
autres et qui gagnera lui il pourra
reprendre langue avec cet électorat oui
pour deux raisons la première la
première la première raison c'est qu'on
met la question de la de la production
et du social lié intimement lié au cœur
de notre projet parce que ces gens-là ce
qu'il demandent c'est de pouvoir vivre
dignement de leur travail ou d'avoir des
retraites décente au regard de leur
contribution à la vie de la nation et
ces gens-là ils ont le sentiment qu'on
leur a expliqué que l'Europe les
éjectait de par le la
désindustrialisation accélérée de ce
pays les éjectai des écrans radars et
quand on leur dit il faut baisser en
sans cesse le coût du travail ils sont
devenus un coût dans la société au lieu
d'être un apport dans la société si on
vous entends bien François Hollande
manuel Val eux ils ont abandonné cette
bah c'était les tests de Terranova moi
je lis les les argumentaires je vois
Terranova qui vous explique qu'il y a
plus de classe ouvrière que de toute
façon ils sont perdus parce qu'ils
votent plus ou que ils vont au marge et
donc l'enjeu c'est vous dénoncez ce
cette influence aui des cercles de
réflexion comme Terranova oui surtout
leur idéologie qui est exactement
l'idéologie des libéraux qui considèrent
qu'il y a dans l'économie un petit cœur
utiles et les autres qui sont
périphériques qui doivent accepter
toutes les flexibilités qui sont
inadapté et toutes lesx États-Unis que
le procès a été fait d'Hillary Clinton
de ne pas s'être adressé au peuple
américain mais à des minorités qu'elle
soit ethnique ou sexuelle et ça c'est un
défaut de la gauche depuis quelques
années pour vous ex AB alors en France
moins nettement parce qu'on a une
tradition républicaine donc on est moins
dans la structuration des communautis de
population immigrée vous le savezou
honnêtement par exemple sur les
discriminations moi je ne sépare pas la
justice sociale des discriminations au
regard des races de la couleur de
l'origine ou du quartier ou du fait
qu'on est femme donc la la lutte contre
les discriminations n'est pas un
substrat euh qui qui est alternatif ou à
la place du combat
social l'erreur l'erreur entraîné
notamment par certaines recommandations
de thing Tang terraanova alors et pas
seulement par la théorisation qui fait
qu'on parle sans arrêt des classes
moyennes tout le monde alors il y a ceux
qui se pensent dedans même quand ils
sont quand ils sont très riches ou très
pauvres et puis il y a tous ceux qui se
disent les classes moyennes je suis pas
dedans euh la réalité c'est que ce qu'on
appelle les catégories moyennes ont vu
quand même tant pentiellement dans tous
les pays développés avec le libéralisme
leur pouvoir d'achat baisser leur niveau
de vie se la flexibilité s'acroit vous
avez peut-être me démentir mais j'ai
l'impression que vous avez intériorisé
déjà la défaite de 2017 vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de l'enjeu des
législatives Maran et le patron des
députés les républicain monsieur Jacob a
annoncé que la gauche connaîtrait une
débacle encore plus grande plus rude
qu'en 1993 vous n'aviez eu que 57
députés ce sera pire vous pensez l'an
prochain non moi je je je ne tire pas un
trait en disant qu' est législative je
ne suis pas pour la 5e République je ne
crois pas à l'homme providentiel futtil
de gauche qu'on va élire si on veut
transformer la société il faut qu'il y a
un accord programmatique qui permett
qu'on ait une majorité parlementaire qui
sache où elle va et qui a pas fait un
chèque en blanc à un candidat fut-il de
gauche donc c'est pourquoi je vous
parlais de cela parce que je pense que
c'est aussi ce qui permet mieux le
rassemblement que simplement alliez-vous
à mon panage blanc reste que Monsieur
Jacob a bien tort de parier là
parce que je trouve qu'aujourd'hui on
parle du décalage entre la gauche et les
couches populaires il y a eu des couches
populaires de droite sous le GIS
celles-là ne sont pas venus à leur
primaire et je ne pense pas que le
projet de Monsieur Fillon V j'espère et
en tout cas je constate que le programme
de Monsieur Fillon est
à complètement opposé de ce qu'ils
attendent d'un mot qui qui arrivera en
tête de la primaire de gauche pour vous
pari les candidats qui arrivera en tête
jeis je vous dis ça je vais avoir l'air
de de prendre position donc vous ne MZ
pas c'était mon attention cachée vous
l'avez elle était pas très dissimulée
merci à très
[Musique]
vite